hello it is time for
live am I live am I live am I [__]
live yeah I'm live [__] what's good
what's good yeah who's ready for Last of
Us hold up one
second man's got a poop I'm sorry I'm
sorry I took
long Le thing make me poop what can I
say all right who's ready for Last of Us
say
yes yes queen I'm G to hear some y
Queen uh game play
Boom gameplay
on gamer
headphones
on I look so [__] dumb with
these I don't like
them why why don't I just order it takes
so long I can't I can't guys I can't I'm
sorry for being late I'm sorry okay I'm
sorry now I said it now let's play the
game I said I'm sorry and I really
really meant
it actually let me pop out chat so I can
see it better two
seconds two seconds
Gamers you waited like 20 minutes for me
to poop you can wait a you can wait a
little longer I
believe for me to actually be able to
read got some great suggestions in the
chat last time that were completely
[__] wrong remember the rules you get
suggestions wrong your penis ch drop off
don't care my border is too thick well
so is your mom got
them uh oh yeah I don't want the border
on the gameplay actually hold
up
B just want on my
webcam the overlay is making me
dizzy how the [__] do you exist out of
here beta all right let's go
so we're in this really creepy place
it's not really
creepy let me see if I remember how to
play the
game I ain't going to forget to
reload ever
again uhhuh we can craft a stun bomb do
I want to do that no I don't I want to
craft this we have the explosive
arrows I talked to PJ he said he never
even used them he was like explosive exp
arrows i'm like [__] you beat the game
yeah I hope you're listening TJ
non-explosive user
cringe uh let we clear everything out
here oh
shoty ooh do you guys hear the door
there's totally a door that
open am I
crazy or am I just oh G feel is stuck in
the M hold up
Pro ergonomic tips your uh monitor
should be at the eye level it's not
really for me the top should be at eye
level here we go make sure you don't
hurt your neck Gamers you're welcome
feel free to adjust your
monitor right now they definitely heard
that it's a quick Time Event can I do
it I guess not what the [__] happened
there a b they justed yeah I don't have
a beta neck come on cringe what sorry I
thought for sure you couldn't die there
oh what a great way to start
Gamers am I supposed to tap
like I guessed I didn't hit it fast
enough I'm so
sorry they are kind of hot get off of
me all right we know how to resurface oh
wait no never
mind ah [__] got me no stop
it yeah
yeah
yeah your respiratory function just be
like
bro guess we're going to the sewers
huh
ow that hurt okay swimming
now
cool so we went from spooky office to
Spooky sewers okay [__] Seattle hey you
take that back I apologize everyone in
Seattle right now she doesn't mean
it I don't know what her problem is
that's kind of that that's kind of
offensive
sounds like someone's peeing nowah she's
right all right all right so I mixed up
Seattle with another
city is not is Seattle which state is in
Seattle Lane someone said
Washington but I what am I mixing up
Seattle
with where is PAX usually isn't it not a
Pax in Seattle I'm so confused oh
Washington is north of California isn't
it oh I see or is it no so I'm sorry I'm
so sorry America
gang you don't know [__] about Europe so
you don't get to
speak you tell me where Uruguay is on
the map and then we
talk then you can give me your little
speech I clearly missed something over
here Washington is east coast yeah I was
testing you cringe sheesh what am I
mixing it up with
then I think that's what bothers me more
than getting it
wrong oh maybe I'm supposed to swim
underneath how do you dive
again dive
gang Seattle is in Mal oh no not San
Francisco shut up I'm not that
dumb Vancouver no what the [__] Pax I've
been there Pax
West where is
it it has it looked the same it has
trees and stuff it's
identical I'm sorry but my brain is
not
I mix it up with Boston no I haven't
it's not
Boston all right let's uh ignore that
for now and figure out what to do oh
there's something floating here
right maybe I can grab something
no h
yes I'm not stuck I'm just exploring
looking for Loot and
stuff definitely not stuck oh here we
go see I figured out on my own I don't
need you guys there a little bit of
subnotica gameplay
there we swim in the poop
water Last of Us swim in poop water 10
out of 10 best game I've ever
played all right do we jump down
here
yes no not Toronto I'm not that dumb God
damn it it was years and years and years
ago I think uh you guys have your Maps
wrong get me the hell out of
here yeah you could say that that
again Sydney yeah yeah it was Sydney
you're
right well it doesn't it doesn't [__]
matter what matters
is what happens in this game just
kidding nothing matters in this
game it's funny cuz like they can do
anything at this point kill any
character I could not care
less oh my
God I'm telling you I said this before
you can say it again you can replace di
with a dog and the game would actually
be better that's how bad the characters
are they not actually care about
protecting okay
did a little spinner there
here Hospital's there uhhuh good to the
park
why guess I have
to guess Ellie said it what if I don't
want to what if I want to play with
the gaming
machines let's do
this yeah can't tell me what to
do this is
cool oh we got
whistles who's whistling oh there's
people there no that's a smudge on my
screen sorry look it looked just like a
guy that ain't no bird I know that for
sure cuz I'd be whistling and [__] if I
was in Zombie
Apocalypse
smudge
gang my clothes are getting smudged now
dude this is so pretty love the
light [__] dog [__] dude I was
crawling the whole [__] way God damn
it I knew that was
coming oh I got to pull it out yeah
yeah
yes periodically damage you
damn um who the
[__] where what do
[Music]
I that worked
okay whistle
gang actually Jem my lights was off it
was off I swear I turned it
off oh God is she coming
here oh God the camera angle is so
atrocious well we can't go
[Music]
there
um
[Music]
hello it's like it's like I completely
forgot how to play the game after being
away one day I was like Dodge button
listen I'm
old these things
happen all right let's try that
again and I should not have this weapon
on
me should we do use this maybe
this [__] is sent to finding
me yeah let's knock her out [__]
him oh now she doesn't walk that
way I see how it
is so am I still take taking damage from
the
arrow why would they attack me like that
I did nothing
wrong this gr is not so
thick am I wearing my headphones wrong
again oh
[__]
let's get the hell out of here oh for
[Music]
sake I was going to leave any why is she
proning [__]
[__] it's all good it's all
good they'll never
be okay they found
me these things
happen can you stop proning for the love
of God
made it come on
easy God damn made
it find another way in there can I
heal these must be the
scars doesn't
matter Hospital
all right [__] that you better not have
strung our
up made it zero
deaths oh God you see
that um yeah let's make a
heal can I reinforce
this I wish there was a way to heal the
BL
BL yeah I said heal the
blade you got a problem with that take
it up with the
cheap room 2011 see what we
got bing bong bing B sweet stereo
section thing
yeah someone doesn't make their bed
[__] crazy people is this is an open
window I think I'm actually supposed to
go
there let's look for loot
first or we have some
downtime
yes do I ever have problems speaking
Swedish if I haven't done it for a long
time
yeah for
sure not like actual
problems it's more like uh I have I got
too much of everything it's you stumble
on words sometimes which can be really
really
frustrating um I said someone lost
someone you know like when you lose a
close one that's an expression in
English and then I directly translated
it to Swedish which doesn't work at all
like and everyone thought it was so
funny and I'm like this is not funny
this is s
house I hate
that it's the only room I can go
to should we go up or down let's go
up let's keep shouting
close oh was
that can everyone just speak the same
language that would be great
I'm watching uh food Wars right now on
Netflix it's absolutely ridiculous and I
love
it um we'll break in the window alert
then I feel like I should stay more
selfie right now what happens if we go
down can we even go down yeah we can
should I go
up Let's cross Bo Under the
Stairs
I feel like I want to I don't care if it
or
life Paige don't care hey pills hey that
was definitely worth it hey
more man died with some drugs man all
right we got but we got I don't want
crafting
speed move faster while
prone listening range
mode or craft more trap mine I can have
more traps in main
Mo I'm not sure what I
want 50% is quite a
lot I feel like movement speed
we'll do listening later cuz clearly I
accidentally
prone I don't know why the controls just
don't feel intuitive to
me um sorry did I look
everywhere no I didn't see I keep
[__] pressing it I I feel like it's
running for some
reason well this was open oh we already
checked okay
can you jump across no all right let's
check under here and whoever said
there's a crossbow underneath might get
their penis chopped so we'll we'll see
what happens
here AK behind the
giant God you guys are so [__]
annoying
I played dark I think I played Dark
Souls 3 and people kept saying behind
the giant like 50 million times and it
was so far off from where I
was all right there's no [__]
crossbow let's get real
here stairs not
ladders all right well if you're wrong
it's Chip
chop guess I have nothing better to
do
here well isn't this well that was
actually worth it
nice Bing
Bong did I go through here I can't
remember all the rooms look the same I
feel like I did yeah I just didn't see
it
doesn't go anywhere else yeah this is
definitely where I was I just missed
some extra
Stu did you mean under the stairs in
this
building cuz then you could have said
under the stairs inside or something
like
that I don't need a hint what
now no there's no stairs all right well
you y'all can suck a
dick suck a big fat
dick you're just delay you're why why
are you like
this what made you this way
[Music]
huh [__]
monsters behind the truck okay I'm just
going to keep
going I think I can
fit cut off their dicks all of
them Joel has the crossbow oh okay wow
that's so cool now I regret streaming
this I crawl I crawl I'm
in I'm in Grass I
swear
how do I swap
ammo oh it's a swap weapon my
bad I could throw a bomb in there now he
is free now now he's free search for
stragglers maybe I should have not
waited all right let's take these guys
out did you hear what Lily did I did
shameful but not all that
surprising so these are two so I can't
get those their poor mother she should
have sensed that something was
off poor Lily F's in the chat for
Lily
that was
close who was there was it
them oh
there not sure what the best CA of
action I always feel like they find you
somehow let's wait for this guy to move
oh there's
more see
see okay we got to try crossing
here oh no no
[Laughter]
no he was looking right at
me nailed
it
all right let's go this
way
perfect no one's
here sneak sneake snake
snake snake
go
oh no oh there's two of them oh God
don't come here a God damn they always
come here
somehow [__] I'm
[Music]
close I'm out of the
open I'm in the grass bro I'm in the
grass bro come on
relax I'm in the grass bro come
on sneak
thousand can't see me but here I am
sneak Master
64 let's throw a bottle that'll throw oh
never
mind watch this
watch this can I throw while I'm
prone
bottle I got to make it to that grass
somehow so I got the people on left and
right but she's she's uh preoccupied
with the bottle the little bottle
incident we don't talk about that move
I should have shot her tonight
[__] look at this dumb B anything don't
see anything so many of
them oh oh no they are not coming
here are
they which side are they walking on oh
this side keep forgetting I can listen
snake snake snake snake snake snake I'm
a little bit bit bit of a snake snake
snake snake sake I'm a little bit better
snake yeah snake
gang oh behind the truck here's where
the crossbow is guys wow thank you so
much for the help you guys are the best
I love my fans
again I keep wanting to run by pressing
this [__] button let's do it
snaking what was that a snake
perhaps could that have been a snake oh
[__] I want to shoot so bad but I
probably snake snake snake snake snake
snake nobody sees me because I'm I'm a
[__] snake I'm a snake I'm a snake
nobody sees me I'm a snake snake snake
snake snake snake
snake everybody now snake snake snake
snake snake snake oh
God uh I'm a snake I'm a snake I'm a
snake I'm a snake I'm a
snake I'm a snake yeah they fell for the
old God damn it who sees me
now
oh God all
[Music]
right sorry about that one bro oh he's
de Austin what happened to Austin not
Austin snake snake snake I'm a snake
nobody s I'm a snake snake snake snake
snake snake snake where am I supposed
was I supposed to literally just go up
there she HD in the grass no I didn't I
didn't I didn't I
swear I'm I'm a snake I'm reload let me
reload hey I'm a snake what the [__] who
shoot the
snake
[__] I like how I made it through the
whole [__] thing
and yeah you'll never find me again
snake snake
snake ow [__] [__] I see
you all right oh
God sorry about that bro
oh oh did your friend die I'm so sorry
about that
bro I'll never find
me yeah shoot shoot nice shot
bro snake snake snake snake snake snake
nobody sees me CU I'm a [__] snake
yeah you'll never find the
snake dumb
[__] all right let's blow them
up surprise [__] quiet snake
join the snake Gang [__] she can't have
gone far
true
[__] should we blow him up it's so
tempting
sleep snake snake snake oh my God they
just keep keep
coming maybe I should just
go I feel like this is where I'm
supposed to go and I was right there but
then there's that there so I don't know
where I'm supposed to
go
kind of lost and
confused maybe in
here to the
house let's try
it
yeah this is
right okay we got
it I really wish I increased the hearing
thing
now oh there's two ways in here
even reload my b
sorry about that
guys
hey all right I reloaded my
bot I just heard
someone very
close
[__]
oh how and
[Music]
who someone sees
me
stand still thank
you it happens to the best of
us crisis
adverted okay
breathe
[Music]
thank
you oh nice should we do a little
surprise jump on this
guy [__] I really want to kill
him can you play the whole game without
killing anyone I feel like you should be
able to there's a guy coming from the
stairs now this is not ideal
oh no they're going to find the
body okay we'll get this one
there oh there's someone behind me
too are they not going
up
you coming up
bro [__] it let's just go
then this is cool situation I like
this oh
God just wish I could see them better
it's kind of like where do they see me I
don't
know nailed
it
yeah I don't want to use the bomb arrows
when I'm trying to stealth that seems to
bit I mean I know I shot the guns
but are there anyone up here n they're
all
gone we did it that was
easy [__] grass snake I'm a snake you
hear wind
snake
is this another way of entering is it
worth checking for loot or is this
literally like a
circle wait what did I walk in a
circle I
did I know I did I was just testing you
guys as all oh there are more I see
them okay let's get this guy with that
bar
now okay okay all
[Laughter]
right I didn't I didn't take in account
the drop but you
know it is what it is
man he took an it literally took an
arrow to the
knee listen I can more of them where are
they coming from sounds came from over
here where are they see me
I really should have upgraded the other
thing seems we weren't as thorough as we
thought they're here
somewhere there they think it's too
cringe at least it's not the dog snake
snake snake snake snake snake I'm a
little bit bit of a
snake hey we can park here sweet
oh
God we should probably try and stop
through
this snake snake snake snake snake snake
I'm a
oh I'm a t with a B bit of a
snake well that's not
good
D
brick I swear I'm a snake
I'm a snake I'm a snake look the
difference it's all good it's all good
snake oh okay so they take damage if you
don't pull it out got
it here we'll do
this we'll set up a little base
here she's
gone carve her out
she's
gone she must have transformed into a
snake Jesus bro you're not leaving this
place she fell for the old snake in the
grass trick where' she
go it
down a [__] there's two people there let
me do another
one trap time oh two and
[Music]
one no God damn it I didn't back
off God damn it whoops oopsie zero
deaths that doesn't count if you kill
yourself I forgot to reload my snake
it's a classic error a lot of people
make that
mistake okay how about this we place it
here and
then we make a distraction there
W there's something over there
guys and then we muched them go boom
boom while I
sneake can we do
that not going to investigate on that
very suspicious sound oh she's
coming big brain idea I know nothing
here no no I'm here look I'm here
please come I'm right
here it's so loud I'm sorry it's [__]
scared
me Jes scour the area we're not alone
really what what gave you that
idea your friend blowing up the pieces
is that an indicator
all right we should take this girl
out oh no wa maybe
not I guess I could sneak by
now oh no wait minut maybe
not there's a snake in the
grass don't turn around please oh God
that's another one snake snake snake
snake no don't move God damn it thank
you just like
that
snake
snake who sees me all the [__] time
there's someone seeing me God there's no
cover
here okay nice we can get banded truck
oh my God there's a crossbow here guys
who
I could have gone under the truck
really really can I get my arrow back oh
[__] [__] [__]
[__]
what what it's just a sizzling
snake all
right I didn't know I could shoot the um
[Music]
what does that
mean does that mean they found a dead
body or
something they'll never find me
here can I jump over there maybe I
should do
that this [__] moves around okay
now I can't
[__]
okay uh what do I
do
[Music]
did I just stun myself it's all right
it's all
[Music]
right hey
hey don't [__] this is my
for no don't jump over I'm healing I'm
healing I'm healing I'm healing I'm
healing
bro
Eva oh no not Eva where's his
friend he hiding literally there oh
that's hilarious snake snake you won't
Escape okay hey
hey [__] missed got you yeah [__]
Pro game play [__] Yeah I think that's
it bald guy for the last oh the city
it's nice of her to wait when I was
healing I got to respect that at least
[__]
hospital my machete is a bit
down thank you forgot to reload my
machete hold up
guys okay we good
G
oh you got to pull it out to reload got
it
done reload the snake
done that was probably the most fun in
Era in the game so far I like
it
get to blow people up who doesn't like
that do you think they have James car
Charles
collection James
Carl's there's a lot of places to hide
here but I just think I honestly just
killed all of
them
you can shoot while prone yeah I noticed
that bit
late Lake Hill hospital I think this is
it watch for big red sign thanks
Ellie can you teach me what buttons to
press so I don't embarrass myself
Ellie it's a brick to reload
there
it's pretty sweet
damn we're almost at 69 let's get it can
we hit 69 please
please hey remind me at 5:30 to publish
a
video am I supposed to go here
NOP must be through the mascara
store must I miss
something here we go
okay hello don't shoot don't
shoot I'm innocent I didn't kill anyone
I'm Swedish I'm Swedish don't hurt me
I'm Swedish what the [__] wrong with
you [__] I shoot you
now yeah come here [__]
oh I definitely [__] shot him what
the
[__] I shot you don't shoot shoot
Swedish Swedish
Swedish okay I run and shoot
you now we're even Even
Steven
Ren there's more coming right now isn't
it I'll find you re oh please please
please come in
please don't come in yet though oh he's
already here [__] where'd you
go sorry bald man you f to die [__]
sneaking he dead as hell he found me he
wasn't
wrong anyone else Jesus Christ can you
imagine Ellie going like that
anyone
right Hospital you kill Joel you son of
[__] [__]
you damn Ellie's really killed a lot of
people does anyone have a body
count at least two dogs they better be
in the
credits
[Music]
all
right snake
snake
snake a
[Music]
snake when I get the guitar later we'll
play the official snake
song part in the backyard
remix what happening
boys how the [__] do floor and [__] fall
down no one uses it and floor will be
like
bruh you know what I'm
saying oh
man God damn
damn I'm so
sore I don't know why same work at feels
super sore oh I
missed but I'm full anyway unless it's
a a vile of blood then I do need it it
does look like it
actually yes
sweet I could have picked up that giant
hammer
really I kind of want
it is that
true all right wa wait wait
wait upendra
KS will get banned and chop off P&P if
you're
wrong I can't go back for [__] sake well
then you're wrong chopped off pee
instantly sliced wall of PE Kendra
congrats you just earned a spot dumbass
anyone else want to waste my time go
right
ahead God damn
it hey you missed uh that ammo at the
beginning of the
game you know
that should go back all right sorry
about
that up or down
well that's the eggs is that the same
area as I
was no oh my God it
is
ironic well up it
hey
yes that's cool
damn Toronto is so
pretty this feels like a shootout area
doesn't
it better still be there Nora feel like
I'm always expecting something to happen
based on the layout of the
map hey she's here we found
her or maybe not I could be
wrong maybe they pulled one of those
switcheroos
all right well well
well I was wrong for the first time
ever in my life jump down
[__] or should we go
here there ton of stuff there I think I
prefer
Solid Ground for
now I'm full of bottles dang
it wish it was an upgrade you can keep
two
bottles maybe you can put one bottle
inside a bottle and double bottle that
way you could reload your
bottles I'm just saying people are
giving this 10 out of 10 but you can't
do that so I don't really know what
people are basing it
know it's not 5:30 it's 2 hours from now
[__] penis shut up it gets shut
off cool that was was of
time woo
dive 10 out of 10 doesn't even
di the hell is
this
oh
man little tedious just walking through
empty areas but all
right I literally [__] came from
here where do I go
then
there's a hole to crawl
pits yeah you guys are just I'm not
listening to a single [__] Comet
anymore
e water plants are so
nasty people cancel people left and
right but why aren't we canceling water
plants like something
productive can't we can canel mosquitoes
or something
instead what if we just can
s did you find her yet [__] hey
boats
sweet we're definitely going to have to
dive under not to not get
oh [__] where do I go up here
es [__] are they talking
about what's the point of this area can
I go up
here
Ellie oh swim under got
it brain so large got a six
pack
what the
hell I got a dive and
lift dive and lift yeah dive and lift uh
dive and LIF yeah dive and LIF
uh submerge
gang doing pretty good s that so far in
this play through feel pretty good about
it oh [__]
oh he's listening to
headphones what is that song again is
that hotline what is it called Hotline
Miami he's playing hotline she's playing
Hotline
Miami that's so [__] good it's on the
VA we're in the hospital they're
clearing the upper floors that's so
great kill her
kill yes bit you
dead
[__] that was
dumb there it is it's allot Miami is
that what it's called I keep
forgetting bro the devil of hot Li Miami
is so talented I remember playing this
game before hot Li Miami became a a big
thing he made this racing car where you
racing car game does anyone remember me
me playing that uh
uh it was this racing game where you
play as people that wanted to become
cars
genius and he made this other like
really music heavy based game I don't
remember it it was like a very short
one it's
cool when talented people
succeed unlike me yeah let's plays woo
such a good
soundtrack I knew I recognized him
somewhere we got too much stuff
Gamers maete almost dead this is so
sad pick up the V like come on
word is we're almost wrapped up good I
got my girl waiting for me at the are we
going to sh me get on the
boat hey we get the job
done bet you do oh this is not
fair I'm telling you man data Soldier
makes these shifts so much
easier sure I'll keep that in
mind I really wish I operated this
sounds like scars are getting
closer that's our guys exting those oh
[__] he's right there did you hear why
we're all getting called up to the yeah
come come come want us to
ret come come I heard we might take a
fight for
them no way not after went went down
last time
even all right let's just go [__]
now death ass
[__] what if he just goes hey she's
here we need it and you want we need it
and you want we're Tomahawk gang
now oh
[__] oh
God all right we're going to have to
oh [__] off [__]
off I want those
[Music]
pills but it's dangerous to be in there
Snake
no
no [__]
stop with with the dogs
man [__]
hell damn you got long arms
Sly grab it please thank
you you didn't see me but here I
am Arrow Master
64 shoot is that sign in the
way stand still stand still stand still
stand still stand still stand still
stand still stand
still gotta Sleep
Gang oo can we get this
guy walking
away
surprise
[__]
[__] don't [__] swore
ell under the boat
gang are they getting so CL use bricks
to distract dogs okay great no [__]
[__] from now on this playthroughs sole
purpose is to not kill any of the
dogs I keep I hear footsteps but I can't
see
anyone someone killed Kevin not Kevin
[__] took the entire courty why Kevin
was a
loser
they'll never find me
[Music]
here um okay
so no got nothing you think I can make
this jump and not be
seen
quiet nice
I think the dog is coming
though who could do such a thing [__]
killing Kevin dude I know oh
[Music]
God I think they found
me do they find
me
hey
that is a [__] tank
dude who who sees me oh [__] oh [__]
[__] look at this look at this [__]
dude
hello oh the dog's
[Music]
coming run away from the dog run away
from the dog listen run away from the
dog no I'll take it out I caught her
there God damn
it who's shooting me Sho move up I'm
sorry doggy boy I'm sorry I'm oh I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead okay I
can I can still make it I can still make
it I can still make
it don't let her get away not kill the
dog no bad dog bad dog bad God damn it
all right fine that's fair that's fair
it's really hard not killing the dog god
damn it that was fair fair game dog all
right so we could kill this guy here
right where'd he
go
[Music]
okay
hello
do I have a brick yeah I do let's have
the brick ready more than
anything oh for [__] sake God damn
it over here
Emma not
Emma still God damn
it how how did you shoot me all right
get up uh we should probably
hide I think the dog is coming oh oh
[__] we can't go here oh
[Music]
am okay okay here we
go
bottle [__] it's not I'm sorry
I'm he just wants to
play yeah go away run
away stop
stop stop stop
stop
stop do I have to kill the
dogs is that the only way to do
this okay there's clearly a ton of
people in there that I should watch out
for so let's not go in
there
[Music]
oh who sees me oh
who and why someone
there behind the door uh
where Emma move in all right I got this
i got this i got this i got
this he's
running
no look alive
[__] that was my
move [__] I thought this is good hiding
spot oh
[__] heads
up
uh oh
[__] run don't fight yeah it feels like
that kind of area that's where I got
stuck last time I felt so bad for
playing so badly and then I realized
wait I wasn't even supposed to fight
them I was clearly supposed to just run
through this
area um let's try that then I just don't
know where to
go yeah
yeah I suck you're all pro Gamers I get
it should I kill this
guy [__] her it was a girl I'm so
sorry look at my bottle it's all
smooshed okay this is where I was
supposed to go she has shotgun
ammo kind of want it nope so you're
telling me this [__] had a shotgun but
no ammo
in
oh all right at least we know where to
go
now we could take this guy out with the
arrow or we could not kill him at all
but that's where's the fun in
[Music]
that oh another
one don't call the cops
oh no it's the the Dog Saw
me I'm panicking I'm panicking I'm
panicking dumb dog so
dumb he's going to smell me I can't stay
here for too
long
oh I needed blankets [__] my
bad can the dog [__]
off this is not where we're supposed to
go at all I literally walked in
circles for [__]
sake I was so happy I was like oh we
went the right
way
well I need
that I'm a snake I'm a snake
seriously I guess we got to go through
there somehow and I got
lost
okay
can't be that many
left stuff on the ground
here
yoink
nope let's go up here
again kill the dogs what's wrong with
you oh God they got back up don't
they
okay okay
nice walking in circle
gang we'll use that for the dogs we'll
just stun
them that'll
do do I have a silencer can I make a Sil
I still have a silencer oh I do one more
shot oh [__] that was
close oh [__] there's the
[Music]
dog I'm
sorry guess we should have to switch
ammo
now
do not come near me
dog it will be the last of
dogs [__] sake I the Dog Saw
me no did I seriously missed that
shot we lost another
Soldier someone still out
there bad things happen to good people I
don't know what you wanted me to say
we're getting
slaughtered
whoa Ellie's a badass
dude you didn't see me but I take your
loot I've literally been through here so
many times oh no
oh the dog's name is bear I can't kill
bear that's such a cute
name don't tell me the name of the
dog I couldn't bear killing
bear so is that going back like where am
[__] am I going let's just run
here oh my God I walked in circles God
[__] damn it God damn it
well we made it we made it zero deaths
and we didn't kill the dog [__] you
naughty dog you can't make
me can't make me worth it worth
it is a crossbow Under the
Stairs
there's a crossbow upstairs on the
ceiling okay got you thanks thanks
guys that's pretty fun game
play I know I'm not the best gamer in
the world I don't think I'm
terrible think we're doing all
right I'm try my best at
least all right it's it zombie time
now a
man never really understand notes in
video games that are really
long
I can only remember one or twice I guess
I don't read them of them but they
rarely have a impact it just feels like
all right guess I read that you
Nora oh we found
her is that you Nora you son of a [__]
Norah
Hora that's a swor in Swedish in
case legit can't go through here
how do I get
through
oh vent
time L conveniently people will have a
conversation while I crawl through the
vent
time is it yeah I figured it was IQ
maybe ifed Abby would
himself the [__] was Abby here I'm not
stupid you're going to tell us where she
went when Isaac talks to us about this
I'm getting tired of this Nora Nora
today was a good day I'm not going down
for
her apparently that's his own favorite
song
careful
careful Nora the
explorer well I'm going to explore it I
want to make a silencer it was really
useful back
there do I have a brick no [__] I can't
reload then sorry guys
make sure we're reloaded on everything
else so that's explosive okay got
it I should have a lot of shotgun ammo I
feel like
nope no I don't let's make sure it's
reloaded
anyway I can't make a
suppressor I scared myself I don't have
enough all right let's go through feel
like a cinematic is coming
up don't
scream
shoot put that [__] down put that [__]
down make me sandwich got good joke
feelings she looked like she had a tray
that's why that's why you remember me I
don't remember her was she in the
beginning yeah
you remember
me what do you want dead you're dead
Abby was here
earlier where'd she
go I don't know like you shoot
me the sound will have every Soldier
come running you'll still be dead she
did look a bit like Dianna tell me where
she went and I'll think about letting
you
go we could have killed
you maybe you should have yeah or maybe
you should have stayed the [__] out of
Jackson where's
Abby that gun is going to make a lot of
noise she must know that you still hear
a
screams
what a don't give me this boohoo [__] I
hear them every night ah [__] off no
you're
dead yeah yeah that little [__] got
what he
deserved oh
[__] hey oh you dead your mom dead
play Oh I couldn't shoot the game didn't
let me what the
[__] [__] ass
game I [__] had
her guess I died I guess I died guys I
guess I died I guess I did God [__]
damn it godam what the hell was that
I got a PE PE be right back go make a go
stretch or something I don't
know
God damn it's hot in here
how was your
stretch 10 out of 10 mediocre I want to
know all the I almost put on these
headphones so much more
comfortable now where were
we I put on the wrong controller what am
I doing
so I'm supposed to chase her that's so
annoying over here all right I won't
shoot you I'm
sorry [__] you dead you're super Dead
Escape this you're super duper dead
you're so dead Nora Nora go explore us
somewhere else am I right got him it's
going to be long I'm going to go around
cuz I saw this my brain is so large it
hurts sometimes Nora you're so dead Nora
Nora you're going hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey stop stop stop you can't hit me
you can't hit me you can't hit me you
can't hit me
Nora am I supposed to shoot
her spooky
Nora Nora where did you go aa oh there
you
a Nora you can't hide from me
[__] hey there it is
you going to die
Nora yeah yeah you're going to die ow
that hurt don't hurt I'm
Swedish am I supposed to I don't know
when I'm supposed to shoot her and when
I'm supposed to chase
her oh sorry come on hey hey careful
could hurt somebody throw down your
weapon
okay no no wa yes push her push her Spar
that [__]
yeah back up your gun down yeah nor gun
die shut the [__] upun down get
back you have nowhere to go well needed
a
she use her cushion okay yes smart
that's
smart you should have shot her before
the
[Music]
fall oh yeah she's immune that's epic
she's going to
turn
take oh oh wait wait let me do this
really quick if I can get a quick MTI
power doing on doesn't matter find
the ah oh no there was a clicker I could
have made them
fight ah God damn it I made it harder on
myself I'm just I'm just
[Applause]
am I wearing my headphones wrong
again come
on yeah sneaking sneaking hell yeah hell
yeah which one is left and which one is
right okay I don't understand you
go he's going to zombie right that's
awesome Justice for Joel hashtag let's
get a
[Applause]
trending that was fun see the game has
its moment for
sure all right is there anything I
should look out
for oh she's coughing and huffing
huffing and
puffing [__] you dead you going to turn
into a plant
[__] you a flipping plant
[__] let me explore here maybe they
have
stuff nope just
boxes yes here it
comes did I forget to reload God damn it
sorry reload for Jo my bad [__] you
were
plan oh God oh
God
yeah anyone anyone got a golf
club doesn't let me pick up my guns hey
Nora smells like the [__]
get oh don't think don't try it then
again I have The High
Ground oh she's turning already
dude use the crossbow thanks
guys where's
Abby brething
SP I'm immune
[__] you're
her yep you heard of me I ain't heard of
you you
Firefly there are no fireflies anymore
photo Sensi sensitized
[__] come on Ellie where's
Abby I'm [__] dead anyway why would I
tell you
anything cuz we can make this
painful because I can make it
quick that shot looks so cool so much
worse you want to be a fruit you want to
be a fruit or not think about what he
did how many people are dead because of
him well I I've killed a couple too you
know it's your last
chance
I'm not giving up my
friend cool more fun for
me oh yeah I'm
pressing a come
on it's not a golf club
but it's
something it'll do
if I was Ellie I would have definitely
brought a
driver was there a choice there where if
I didn't press the buttons she would
live or was I forced to kill her I'm
just going with it I don't really
care is I supposed to feel bad
there it's me
Revenge bad all this is we killed like
[__] 100 people already
like what different does it
make are you okay I slept in the shower
it's no big deal is that your
blood she's Hiding Out
near in this
Aquarium
okay you want to you want to have a g-
fuel relax a bit let's get you cleaned
up let's get you relaxed here's a here's
a sex pack of G
fuel feel all
good have a Pepsi just relax
should it torture her more Jesus Christ
guys so this part I saw on Twitter cuz
people said it was really impressive to
pull off a shirt in
animation but I don't get it it's pre-
rendered isn't or is it I don't how is
that
impressive CGI people tell me cuz I I
don't get
[Music]
it
it's actually all in engine
oh that's
[Music]
cool Look Away
gang it isn't pre-render okay then isn't
really impressive I made her talk
it is [__] pre-rendered what are you
talking about all cut scenes are
pre-rendered am
might it's
okay you guys don't know anything about
computers clearly I don't want to lose
you I programmed many games in my life
games
good
[Music]
two years earlier oh juran's back hell
yeah get
hyped this is a Joel cut scene cut the
cut the cut the cut the cut cut cut cut
Pediatrics I'm playing tap Titans while
playing last of us because I'm so
gripped I'm just kidding it is fun I do
I I can't I can't not even if I
try I'm actually in some ways
behind I mean I really enjoy playing the
game it's not like that but this is the
story got me so uninvested
a lot of times when I do Let's Plays
people get really mad at me because I'm
not invested in the story and they're
usually not that good of a stories at
least in my
opinion so I find it hard to get
invested and but people get mad at me
I'm like but it's a bad story but for
once I'm playing a game with a bad story
and everyone is on board with that it's
not good so there got to be something
um why' you all
leave feels good man I think that's why
I'm enjoying it I think if if everyone
else thought the story was really really
good and here I was playing it I would
[__] hate
it what is
this e no nose
gang that's your arm Ellie so this is
her discovering about the vaccine
probably could that be
it yeah she's in the fireflies base that
makes sense
[Music]
brain look like a plant
though man when I think
about DNA and how complex that is the
human body okay fine but DNA something
that we still don't really fully
understand I'm like how the [__] does
that exist in nature how
that's the only thing that made me feel
like um wait uh I no no I don't I can't
make sense out of this the they brought
up a good point of just how
long it's been and that we as humans can
barely even comprehend that time for
things to
develop which makes
sense but still I got to shake my
[Music]
controller
this
crazy Evolution perfect sense DNA I'm
like wait how wait that just exists by
chance oh
okay how help me help me understand
Gamers there people have left
already I don't know know which group
I'm going to
join I was one of the ones that wanted
to go after The
Smuggler and the
girl I
said even if we found her or by some
miracle found someone else that's
immune it make no
difference cuz the only person who could
develop a vaccine is
dead by some miracle found someone else
that's immune it make no
difference go found someone else that's
immune it make no difference vaccine
don't work on
fungus just got to wash your hands
bro
hey
yes come here oh the hell were you
thinking running off in the middle of
the night like that
you talk to
me well you don't just leave me a
goddamn not you don't talk to
her tell me I'm glad to explore this at
least in cut scenes what happened here
flashbacks
if you lie to me one more
time I'm
gone you will never see me again tell
the truth
Joel shouldn't be that hard but if you
tell me the
truth I'll go back to
Jackson no matter what it
is
come on Joel come
on
damn just say
it
Joel making a
vaccine would have killed
you would have killed you
yes so I stop
them
damn
oh my
God but she knew
[Music]
right don't you [__] touch
me
I'll go
back but we're
[Music]
done that
sucks that a really good flashback see
the more I play the less mad I am that
Joel died the more mad I'm just like how
he died and when whoa that looks so
good
hand looked a bit weird but the rest is
really good oh my god look away gang
sheesh I ain't looking at
it I can't
move so anyway DNA
what do you guys think of that that was
a really cool cut
scene I like that it's probably one of
the better
bits
Dina
Jesse it makes sense now where she was
so um
angry in the beginning of the game or
distant I guess rather she seemed a bit
off the
warrier hey look Joel what's your
favorite it's understandable she would
be upset in the beginning but you can't
hold that against someone
forever this is a cool area it's back of
the stage isn't it got all the props and
[__]
all right now remember I was going to
say with with DNA it's like okay just
cuz you can't really understand it it's
such a fallacy to just point it to
something else okay we don't understand
this so
therefore
this that's my final
Point not that interesting okay squeeze
through yeah sque
gang it's got to be a fun job to make
set
props set set prop gang be like bro you
don't
know Dina
Jesse we can play guitar now right where
are those
too I feel like it's okay yes he killed
all the people to stop them vaccine but
if I feel like if she was going to die
it should have at least been her
choice to make and she didn't know going
into it that it was going to kill her
right I don't remember if that was the
case or
not
snake
G for
life saking for
life I am a snake snake snake
[Music]
snake
beautiful thank you thank
you that's a cool feature I'm the Third
[Music]
Wheel she don't look too
hot
she had a rough
night barely could get her to keep water
down you should have woken me
up is she pregnant oh my God he doesn't
know
yeah refresh if you're
lagging
420 why you came out
here but we got to take her back I agree
she needs real care and she's not going
to get that yeah I
know why don't he take her back
then but I can't just leave
Tommy he's out here because of
me maybe you could take her back sounds
good she's not going to leave without
you oh come
on you can't surely be that
stubborn screw
it let's get Tomy I think you screwed
enough
Eugene this aquarium that girl told you
about Tommy hasn't found Abby it we'll
post up there until he
does that might look look cool stretched
my neck when I worked out today God damn
it leaving Dina by herself I don't know
how her
orders
okay let's go tell her we're leaving
then I'll just meet you up
front
yeah it's a very gloomy
game I remember last of us at least
there was some light moments you know I
guess the flashbacks are but not the
last
one
by hey
babe I need you to lock the door for
us
[Music]
okay I definitely don't think their lack
of chemistry has anything to do with
them being a gay couple like if that was
a guy I still would have thought it was
really cringe calling each other babe
after your map showed the aquarium along
the smoking weed and having SE like I
don't know it's just yeah it's just not
I don't know why do anyone this
city you going to help me out come on
help me out cuz I remember playing the
DLC was really cute okay go for it I'm
just not filling them together at
all
di should have been a dog my uh my
statement still
stands dog could have gone
pregnant could have had
puppies could build an army of
ss these are great great ideas like I
don't get enough credit that we're
hoping to find Tommy at the
aquarium I didn't tell her you knew can
I go in and look places or do I have to
follow him what happens if I don't
follow
him this aquarium a wolf face I don't
think so Norah said siging out
there tell you why did yeah uh we
haven't gotten up station uh falling out
with some fireflies now former
fireflies what kind of falling
out uh he was a
Smuggler and they disagreed about some
Goods fight broke out some of them died
yum yum guess they want
payback
damn that change anything for you
nope nope I need to get clear on
something when we find Tommy you're good
with going home yeah no you'll be
leaving some of those [__] alive
Dina should be back in Jackson okay
good no I'm not [__] done if we find
Tommy are you
serious
damn
amazing
wow this looking up looks so
good not so
good
wow can I craft anything by the way
slurp
gang [__] locked let's check in
here seems pretty obvious
Eugene definitely upgrading uh Can I by
the way
I see a light through
[Applause]
here
jammed yeah durability of silencers is
good too
actually guess it's all good at this
point crawling faster is good
too
yeah I have a feeling Eugene's going to
die and then we can raise the baby
without him you're kind of a third wheel
Eugene no I don't know how to say this
but yeah you ever worri they're going to
come back to Jackson after us he's way
too nice
too what do you mean I mean we're going
through a lot of their
people their City because of what they
did didn't Abby and her friend from
Jackson of something Joel did
this place isn't like
Jackson I mean Joel and Tommy helped
Abby when she got attacked nice everyone
around them I mean they shot you on site
didn't they yeah they did next time
we'll do this
one
oh
I I'll save it for now I don't have that
much hey give me a
hand Eugene Jesus Christ
dude I don't know why the game is so
long if she was floor gang she could
have put push that
herself I just got to
ask why didn't she tell me about it the
pregnancy listen yeah why I don't
[__] know she'll tell you about it
when where did you hear it
from should one of us go left and the
other go right last time it won't be
like
last I'm nervous oh God we're all
nervous they have the whole Coast
covered they're going to shoot us out of
the goddamn water hey have faith what do
I do here sound like them don't look
like there's a CH p think of what will
happen if we succeed did that [__]
not make a sound oh it did up last
second it saved
us don't see anything oh God trespassers
WIP Skyler I kind of missed that up
angle on them
brick
[__] is he he shooting that
one [__] where are they coming
from there
we oh my God Ellie just jump in they
went over there no they didn't why am I
pressing all the wrong buttons there we
go sorry
guys Lally one
guy the hell they go nope spread out do
a sweep find them quick think we can
sneak
[Music]
past didn't see me but here here I
am oh my God you [__] crazy bottle
[Music]
gang listen that them I'm on it oh
there's two guys I didn't
see we good or what I'll clear over
here oh yeah we're clear Jesus carry it
came from that
way here here no [__] there was
more get them I got your sick yeah you
can shoot Eugene that's all
good behind you
where oh God
found Eugene can you [__] shoot
him I got to
[Music]
heal yeah these wolves man so trigger
happy yeah right [__] up C they shoot
at anything about F something I swear I
shot another one in the head stars is
all I've heard them
called you run into any no you're
lucky they just like shoot at anything
it's like what the hell
man I keep wanting to run with circle I
can't believe it uh have I reload this
yes I swear I shot one of them in the
head there it
is thank
you thank you kind
sir let's get the
loot
hello thank
you
oh I definitely have not used the
bottles enough there so
fun God damn it I'm
full
squeeze rest in power rest in power
squeeze some lemon and juice to get
lemon
and
only oh Bo
I feel like it's worth it looking around
I know you guys are a bit anal about
loting everything
but suck not to have the option when you
want to be creative and [__] in
games with how you kill them cuz I'm the
killest the the realest the
frest let's go up here can you no oh
full am I reloaded
yes uh oh that was Eugene [__] you
scared me a
bit the hell are you doing out in the
open you
loco
I'm on car
now what's up with all these posters
it's a bunch of comics wait what was
happening here gathering for people who
were really into this stuff like you
basically we were born in the wrong time
man Ellie doesn't know what a comic book
convention
is or com com
store simp question
mark what else does she not
know bing bang
bong are you guys working out since you
saw my video or did you work out before
I'm curious if anyone picked up because
of it floor gang oh come
on don't stretch your neck though God
damn it I don't know how I did
it neck
bad what were you saying
uh so floor gang 20% the muscle increase
when Once things are wrapped up here I
guess at some point it'll get pretty
hard to hide it do you know if she's
going to keep
it I don't how do you do an abortion
during the apocalypse excuse me what
what maybe they have pills uh how long
has she been preggy I don't want to
think about these
things
whoa look at this
mess the
aquarium it's right next to that Ferris
wheel hoping Tomy has the same
info
wow I will never ask about abortion
again in [__] comments Jesus Christ
guys
swim maybe you just have to go under
water and the baby no all right you're
not I'm not joining your awful
comments
ew disgusting
I hear
someone infected o
where Bish
where
oh look out oh God damn it
where all
right all right
relax a you made me waste a shot
Eugene it's hard to see in the
dark I have the lights reflected on me
and then it reflects back on the mirror
and it reflects very similarly to the
light that they
have what are you doing
Eugene nothing you know why
useless let me turn up the brightness a
bit I really can't
see everyone in the Stream be like ah my
eyes oh my
God I'll try staring at two spotlights
you know I can probably turn off one of
them shouldn't make a
difference
ah I don't know how streamers do it
sitting lights on
[__] let's do that does that look
terrible so much more
comfortable yeah you know what let's do
this what a
difference now where was
I right DNA so anyway
guys if I got grabed pass on it you
can't climb
it is it a swim over kind of bit under I
mean not
here oh here we
go thank you dubs Bubby I'm not reading
donations though I'll check it out after
I don't want to take it off my attention
way too
much cuz if I start reading them more
will
come like
zombies we got more what did I
say where oh
is it Molly
[Applause]
time all right you killed him now I may
I wasted them all the time
you you do
[Applause]
it I want to pushed him
up
Eugene is a good shot I got to hand it
to him he's hitting all of
them Eugene Stormtrooper
confirmed come on Eugene you can do it
you can do it you can do it well done
good
aim I guess I can't talk about
[Laughter]
aim oh sad crafting noises
yeah I think you're
right where did you Eugene
go is it time to
swap yeah nah too early
I guess this is a bonus
area bonus
meme why is he
here yeah I think we're not even
supposed to be here it's just like extra
ammo and [__] go team jacks
really you going to keep you hanging
it's cold
man now if you aim properly you get it
all right if you aim
properly
yuck
swim
under yeah hey
fish haha fish go blah
blah just give him the high five you
sociopath he you get a high five and
pray you can't just pra people for the
sake of it then they will never learn
there needs to be
incentive there needs to be actual
progress think you can get through there
let's
see he will shoot good now you'll see
that they implemented that in the
game plus it's a zombie apocalypse we
should not be making hand contact excuse
me one meter distance
I would have come you know if you told
me you were
leaving boohoo I
just I didn't think you'd be okay with
all this I looked up to
Joel what happened to him was messed
up I would have
come am I crazy Joel liked you a lot too
you
know wo used to think I a on you
really they going to make Joel gay now I
mean you're handsome and whatever but
I'm not a your type okay wait look this
what Asians oh damn it yeah that's
obviously what I
meant surprised they made a joke like
that everything's been so uptight when
they
Brothers social jokes that's
cool
we got
bottle make sure we're
ready
getting all the loot
yeah uh-huh uh-huh hey look at this
place is that Alice in
Wonderland why did she make that jump
the floor is lava pip is
pouting classic
classic Grandma secret Adventure classic
hallw makes movies of the wrong things
putting fungus in the kids section
mushrooms didn't exactly carry the same
meaning back then
oh I guess
so kids used to think these were
cute they ain't cute your favorite book
of the kid yeah battle ghosts it's about
these Space Marines who fight off ghosts
Alien
ghosts
sounds nice like something you'd like
let's remove it don't want to waste
it okay what about you
smartass
well my mom only had this one kid book
The Root child about this boy who turns
into a forest to save his village okay
to keep things fresh though my mom would
improvise different
endings
this one time the boy just let the whole
village die gave me
nightmares it's dark that was really
sweet she did that yeah sweet she's
going to go crazy when she hears about
this baby sure I can see
that Jesus what happened up here these
guys really have it in for each other I
think it goes back years wonder how it
all
started who Stacks books like this
crazy what do we got
entertainment a That's a
classic are these real movies no
take it
back still can't
read spectacular action and
explosions all the time
nice I can't
see taking the
byways wow beautiful executed
beautifully
executed I want to see
that you want to watch a movie Eugene I
hear enter the gun
man is
good book signing
event oh
man God damn I'm
thirsty is that a Oh I thought it was a
rocket that' be way more
fun hold on let me S like this one Nick
needs some
rest
ah oh they
dead oh they definitely
dead
W this place is
[__] blood's still wet let's get back
to the street
yeah feel a little
woozy I think I need a
drink give me
um I'm just get some water be right back
for
that's good to know
I don't know what
happened let's feel a bit
lightheaded boohoohoo
H go H go over
yes it's weird I've been playing so long
I didn't expect to randomly just feel
weird had a weird
uh what's up don't think I ate enough
for lunch
any idea where we should
go that might work
where
oh looking at bright scaring in the dark
yeah I'm a
bit I'm always full on this one God damn
it
I should use this gun
more it should be my default zombie
weapon get them
boy oh nice yeah get him got him got him
the area for survivors no but we're ah
ah good job boy no
all right snake
time get your chance we all are they
coming
here can't see me but here I am
snaker
on your left they got a dog they got a
[__] dog
bro
[__] what if we kill him and not the dog
will the dog get me got something
bear oh
[__] they got our Trail didn't
they don't let the
dog [__] you up bab oh god there you
go think someone's here I'll
itep for a
week who sees
me my guy promised to teach me salsa
dancing oh you and find anything right
about now [__]
you oh thank God he turned
around there's nothing here
Eugene come on
man oh no the dog's here
[__] she's got something [__] smell
girl trespassers God damn
it
oh
god oh there you
are yeah dog will never find me
now dog can't swim it's all
good whoa that's
cool
all right we should probably get
up
Ellie can I not go up there oh I can't
go up there oh thanks
Eugene I can't do anything here in the
water move it all
right come
on she's pined down no I'm not oh God
the dog pluck right there
no oh you [__] God damn
it
no oh my
God you're all
dead you hear
me oh my God God [__] damn
it
for [__]
sake I'm
sorry I'm so
sorry
right I didn't want to do
it
no I didn't want to kill the doggy yeah
I had one
goal oh hell
yeah they see me don't
they you didn't see me dogs go to heaven
is cool reset
checkpoint can't whoa what happened to
you damn bro
that's impossible is every dog in this
game called
bear that's so
cute all right about time we use the
shotgun so
[Applause]
sad
oh we only have 29
okay
ooh I didn't want to do
it I'm not to blame I'm in a
sense all right so there's another dog
that we need to watch out for but where
am I supposed to go
exactly
cuz this is not it I thought she was
going inside for a
second
Eugene don't [__] push me
bro I'm on edge
already maybe if I go up again I can see
better where I need to
go
got a dog I
know oh I'm sorry
doggy try looking for the
aquarium
so this is the other end of the area
that's what I assumed we would need it
to go but it's clearly blocked off maybe
inside there
again maybe you have to go through that
building
oh that didn't make a sound
right
swim
gang maybe swim underneath what the [__]
is is that
Eugene what the hell are you
doing that
ass swim under the bus oh
nice oh was we literally just I was
literally there all right fine at least
we got some extra
pills swim game
all right Soo dogs
nice Minecraft flashbacks no no
no so left or
right well there's a sail going on here
so
I say we go
here his name is
Jessie his [__] name is Jessie no
no are you said you're
joking excuse me sir what's your [__]
name who are you where the [__] are
you his name is Jesse
how did I manage to get everyone's name
wrong everyone's name I got
wrong I know the dog's name is
[Applause]
bear I've been calling him jene the
entire game
no no he's he's Eugene he's Eugene
there's no way I got that
wrong all right what do we got I haven't
been using the shotgun that much it's
already pretty
powerful
uh you can put a scope on this I think
we should save up
actually
oh well well well good thing we
saved you
Eugene Eugene
gang I know we could do the scope but I
feel like stability is more
important then who the [__] is Eugene if
he's not Eugene that's what I want to
know he looks more like a Eugene than a
Jessie excuse me your name can I just
have your name
please so it looks like we can crawl
through
there I'll check here
first H maybe not let's check
out oh this is a little Crouch herea oh
never
mind goes to the same spot
probably wait now we were in the
building before okay confused
noises well now I'm really okay I see it
okay
I think Abby picked the aquarium so damn
hard to get
to maybe wait her name is Abby not Deb
I'm just kidding I knew
that I knew
that God I'm so
thirsty Jesus the weed guy was Eugene
Crossing this
we could use that
road it's pretty [__]
far or we use that bungee
jump
woo that's
better come on yeah boats are pretty
silent I like that
idea sometimes I just want to look at
the
game
you know what I
mean I'm like really hungry but I my
stomach is like N I don't want food so
what's the plan I think that's why I
feel weird these guys out steal their
boat definitely taking their boat it's
up to them if they want to get in our
way hopefully it's a small
yes supplies
[__]
yeah climb over for no
reason you can make a lot of
stuff
Tomahawk is almost dead remind me to
replace
it I cannot go back to Jesse now it's
definitely Eugene place is wrecked like
every place in the game at
Le uh Eugene you're in the way
bro
oh oh paid off to go this
way I saw the other thing I picked it
up [__] I didn't look on the lap
whatever ah it's too early for video
actually yeah I'll publish
it
this is how you make content upload
videos while live
streaming get on my [__]
Gamers
Mo 85,000 in here but
damn guess got nothing better to do on a
Monday well watch my video
then
this way come
on oh how did he know
that how he know that oh need
a watch your live stream and the video
at the same time for the ultimate
PewDiePie experience don't call yourself
a PewDiePie
fan take the land bridge to the marina
the rest of you we hold here wait for
orders what the [__] we're supposed to
wait here while our guys are being
sniped we have our
ORD more than enough people to take
one Eugene you might want to turn off
your
[Applause]
flashlight
I have to wait for
him so you climb Faster by
holding which one was
it I can't change
now do you know how hard it is to
remember names I was impressed I knew he
was
Eugene
a this guy's going to have a bad
day we can get to the marina through
here no we're taking their boat just're
shooting with the arrow right there
talking about Tommy we don't know that
who else is it going to
be if it is him he'll be gone by the
time we get there Abby is where he'll be
headed so if we just what if he's in
trouble he can take care of
himself Jesus Christ best way to Tommy
to go after
Abby you do this I'm not saving your ass
again I really hope you make
it thanks
bro you're a real pal you know
that all a real friend
though got the engine back up where
should I put in wish
[__] can I go
[Music]
up what just
happened in the I'm
not
[Music]
where are they I'm so
confused I looked to away two seconds
and I
lost
oh oh there's my uh breath bar I didn't
see
it seems like the no oh my God I didn't
mean to what is she doing heor no you
didn't I think this is the
end isn't X
resurfaced not so much yeah
same
[Music]
they see me in the
water I didn't know they could do that
I'm going to
die she went back there the hell did she
go search the entire
come on I keep making the dumbest
moves so X is down Circle up no wait
opposite it's opposite day
Gamers how do they keep seeing me
though
damn that's a lot of
[Music]
them I suck at
this
all right I guess
it's time to get out that
there Derek Derek here keep back
there can't swim
through go up
please
where'd she go you didn't see me but
here I
am I need to head for head shot I forgot
[__] all right this area should be safe
now
nope oh [__] s I'll go check it out yeah
go check it out
bro no [__] way oh he's
scared like [__] I didn't sign up for
this job oh he cuz he saw the bodies
surprise
[__] maybe report it in next
time
[__] okay now I can swap that's pretty
good
actually let's go to the next area
yeah zero that is pretty good not going
to lie I'm a pro gamer in case you're
who's
he [__] you shot me in the
water man God damn it oh my
God I shot you in the knee
[__] can I have your machete
please God damn it she didn't drop
it that's a sexy
pose oh she pee
herself all right let's not forget to
stop oh he's got BN
Ara the [__] is the fu her
[Music]
down you found me
yeah
okay here it's all clear gamer it's
clear over here there's no one over here
guys any trace of her all clear
here damn it there was someone behind
him I didn't
see oh
God
surprise [__] no no
[Music]
right over
here why won't she
die hey remember when I said we should
stealth Jesus
[__] uh-oh
uh-oh
whoa whoa who threw that
all right that gives us a chance to do
this properly my
bad I should not have shot it was I
thought all right you know what no
excuse that was this
bad sometimes gun go bang bang is fun
you
know not the greatest Molotov either I'm
actually glad I got it
back so if we throw this here well she
come
here the
hell Sarah deaths count them boys snake
snake
snake snake sake there was butle here
guys come on come
on oh they don't see me they don't see
me they don't see me they don't see me
ah executed perfectly
[__] [__] you [__]
[__] I mean I could have just ignored
her but oh God who sees me now oh there
he
is he didn't see
me but here oh
God everyone can see me apparently
anyone got a
visual what about you nothing
yet wait for her to come
him if we can get a head shot on
him I can get the arrow
back let's try let's do
[Laughter]
[Music]
that that was a head shot
right [__] I don't think that was a head
shot there's another one coming up the
stairs
can we crawl through the grass
maybe no one
here absolutely no one laying in the
grass just a
snake
surprise don't scream next
[__] God
damn let's make sure they don't come
behind me okay so the boat is right
there
nice oh they know I'm
here I think it came from over there no
no search search this
[__] he's right there
so
funny I think it came from
me no one in this area no
one same nothing's turned up yeah
nothing
here nothing except death
you dead your mama dead your daddy
dead can't be that many
left
boat might as well look for Loot and
[__]
yeah who's ready to ride a boat me and
Eugene we ride a little boat
Eugene what runes with Eugene spleen
trampoline beep
clean um that's all I got
really Eugene be clean you be clean uhuh
stay with me
now keep forgetting I have the mines
they're so fun
she used them more for the ls for the
LOLs for the Epic Mega
LS thought I saw
something tambourine [__]
hell
Eugene Bey clean when I play my oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
tambourine with your jean oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah tambourine solo from
Tambourine Man where' the boat go there
it is is there anyone in the boat oh no
no no no no no grass grass I'm a snake
I'm a
snake who saw
me oh this guy found a oh it's this guy
should I just get him really quick so I
can get the boat
what's going on she's dead no she's not
someone's out there no what are you
talking
about damn this is swaying a lot though
might be
difficult so he's hidden I feel like I
should just be able to jump down and get
it maybe they'll shoot me but you
know what the [__] is doing this
SCS okay this is definitely a bad idea
can I stop can I I didn't want to go oh
my God [__] I'm dead now
down okay somehow I made it that's so
dumb boat I ride a boat I am a
boat boat go SK
woo yeah SL them SL them can't hit me
I should have realized you have to pull
that [__] engine open of course oh
the steady steady as we
go yeah this is steady
wow
woo okay stop for ice cream yes or no
sneak hundred there's the ferris
wheel oh man
it's very forgiving sometime this game I
like it apparently I can't stop the boat
the boat goost no matter what oh okay
sorry actually I can't stop the
boat oh
man I can't stop won't
stop boom Brom please go
through go through
what yeah boats can go through this
engine won't get stuck it's all good
it's all
good
woo slom gang now
what puzzle
time will this stay open
oh to locate the boat is the boat going
to
disappear why would I need to locate the
boat might as well look around a
bit I feel better
now
don't feel bad
anymore hell
yeah you
dead there's a crossbow under the boat
oh the code is
[Music]
oh are we drawing a
picture
[Music]
let's locate the
safe
damn found a little
hole damn it come
on damn it
what was it 72
64 thanks
guys appreciate the non-rolling
comments so what was the point of
this this is a different area oh I see
okay I was like
what okay it's got to be
Splash savior of the
universe
I'm full of
everything guess I have
to 702
[Music]
64 eyes closed eyes
closed I ni
close oh oh my God first try [__]
yeah grab grab grab grab grab grab grab
grab grab
grabb Dam need to you must shouting
more oh didn't see you but here I
am all
right
all right that was worth
it it's
getting I'm so sorry here we
go alternate vote controls are available
under options accessibility so
apparently this game is very friendly
for handicapped they have all this kind
of modes for Disabilities I think that's
pretty
cool
so technically if you really wanted to
cheat you can just enter those but I
don't really see the
point I like that more uh AAA titles
should do that God damn
it got it
I literally just enjoy Runing
theat
huh don't know what Chad is talking
about
am I
stuck okay we're fine it's got to go a
little
faster I keep seeing those shining
things up the wall and I'm like oh
that's an item clearly
isn't bro I'm so hooked on tap
Titans
whoa God
damn God damn it's good to be a
game let's check in
here
looks like we got some
supplies damn
it in the future we'll have flly dude
he's got boobs in his
crotch there's a new infected out there
look like something wow that's some ugly
[__]
okay so I said that the zombies are a
bit uninspired because it just feels
like the same as left for uh yeah left
for dead
yeah what would be a more original type
of zombie that hasn't really been seen
before cuz you get the Boomer you get
the
spitter you get the fast one and sneaky
ones I know they don't have a spitter in
this game but or would be a new concept
of a zombie the tank
it's like they've done it all apocalypse
is kind of a tire zombie apocalypse is
kind of a tired
concept I thought it was fresh though
with the last of us when it came out
with the plant stuff that's a really
cool
idea leave you're a invisible zombie I
wouldn't fit this
world flying zombie
uh I guess animals don't get infected so
animal zombies maybe snake
zombies crawler would be cool like
Silent Hill too that would be really
creepy I like that
[Music]
oh I wasn't going here
anyway what do I do now
oh God are they coming here am I
supposed to oh are they fighting each
other already God this is weird to
see Captain
PewDiePie Captain oh oh [__] Captain
PewDiePie going
through you didn't see me cuz my boat
goes so [__]
[Music]
fast excuse me
what no oh [__] she sees
me submarine
time we could really snipe them
here actually make use
of
should we do it might be
fun
so oh come on she moved God damn
it pop your head
up
oh
[__] ooh that was
nice
come
on ah
yes
yeah that's some nice
snapping are there
more
no it's more fun playing the game you
want even though it technically doesn't
make sense you know what I
mean oh [__] uh I'm a boat I'm a I'm a
boat you didn't see me I'm a boat you
can't see me you can't see
me [__] it I'll go back
Jesus [__] man's just trying to drive a
boat
here
all right we got two more
shots can we go in
there well this is
unexpected was I supposed to go
here
cool very cool keep looking [__]
what no
way
what hey we got a rope I was supposed to
go here that's so
funny I'm always lost in this [__]
game I guess I can
just why would I toss it down
there what should I
do rope physics check
them what's the point is there something
down
there confused rope noises
you're not supposed to go there it's
optional you can make a zip
line I wish I could get on top
here but that doesn't
help what's the point of the
Rope can I cut the
Rope it's so I can get
down but
why okay maybe there's something let's
check it out then maybe there's
something underneath me that I can't
see
nope yes there is sweet
that makes more sense so which one was
it
R1
woo ah that was a terrible swing oh it's
so awkward I don't think I can make
it
cool didn't expect to be
here that's some cool game
design all okay we can heal up
now more sniping we can do from here oh
epic so you were supposed to snipe
here cool we get more ammo hell yeah
it's kind of cool laying prone
though oh there he is
no too high he's not that
far did I hit the gun what did I
hit there's another one there
right bald gang o I almost
shot
that's too high I really need to make
this
shot stop moving please oh my God I was
just about to shoot Every
Time come
on the tension is cutting through should
I shoot him in the
foot what is he oh there's is there
another one there no that's a rock I
can't I'm [__] blind damn
it
Eugene
gang ah come on let me snipe you
[__] here let's do this longest bottle
of all
time longest bottle throw possible in
the
game oh he's out for [__] sake he's
out in the wide [__] open yeah come
closer Beach
dick you [__]
dick
right so am I supposed to get the boats
still it looks like the water ends here
so let's just jump
down
cool I like the game sometimes I really
do
he's dead as hell oh what the [__]
happened no ammo on these
guys
really should I get the
boat
let me check the building first oh yeah
definitely getting the
boat but I can check for loot while I'm
here brick gang cool I just needed to
reload it is that a little secret thing
or is it this leading in here it's just
leading in
here I feel like there might be
something underneath the stairs maybe
like a crossbow or something like that
you never know could be a crossbow
laying right
there thanks for the Dono hey hey I'm
I'm not reading donations sorry but I
appreciate
you
ooh oh I'm sorry about that bro that was
a sweet shot oh
no oh
no oh that's awful
awful how are you oh you got in the oh
no
is that a Molotov [__] could have used
that in the heart bro that's got to
hurt nice a lot of supplies
here too strong
ow guess you can sneak in this way I
don't think there's any more
loot can't be bothered to check
everywhere but I will check
here cuz that's what I do we check in
the back
room with Eugene and
tambourine tambourine solo
now
see wouldn't it have been bad if they
had a tambourines in the game instead of
guitars everyone plays guitar like
cringe to master the tambourine take
skill heart effort big
brain I can just grab I thought it was
glass
yeah
a brand new
machete well don't mind if I no I don't
have
tape I got way too much
stuff been looting way [__]
much What do we
got flip
it not going to read
it
wait there was an area
here can you go
there no it looks like you can't go
there okay let's get the
boat I love this sort of stuff in
games where
uh it kind of reminds me of half lifee 2
when you drive the boat right and then
you get a
basee and then you clear out all the
enemies and you look around and then you
go back in the
boat high like
two you just get in the boat
man remember when we used to tell foods
to
loot I guess
so not needed anymore
who's this
guy I've learned Gamers I've adapted
I've
improved I've
improvised you know what I'm saying Hell
yeah what's up
Barrel boat
gang
Speed
game oh this is a little spooky I
wouldn't go so quick
here
okay I remember last of us the first one
looked really good but if you compare it
to this it does not look that good what
Flash oh another one of
these for a time though I
guess underneath
gang
hey we got pills
nice yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes okay so we have a choice
now bombs hold breath seems a bit
unnecessary uh faster self kills 100%
speed
[Music]
damn send more
healing no what should I
do I can technically for these
two no wait I
can't silencer
increase some people are saying Health
some people are saying
stealth
I feel like when you're dead in this
game you're dead it doesn't really
matter about the health packs that
much not that I have died or
anything stealth kills so we'll go for
that next
then cool thanks guys appreciate your
input
whoa what a cool
arcade meteor
battles go for
smash oh give me the money give me the
[__] money where's the money
Johnny I don't have it God damn where's
my [__]
money it's coming
bottle
damn yeah all right so what did I say
last time we were going
for Less swaying on this gun would
honestly be
nice I think I'm got to do that
don't hate
me yeah that'll do that'll do little
bling a little PL and bang bang
bong we'll get the B side it's just that
um
[__] now I can take out people on a
greater distance oh God it doesn't sway
less at all what the [__] what have I
done
DDR machine Let's Go imagine Joel and
Ellie they could play together this
could be such a wholesome chunga
moment all the missed opportunities
man my health is full I don't need to
get
those no all right let's do what we came
to do
of course been too easy I know I wanted
but whoa holy
moly oh no why didn't I check it first
damn it how am I supposed to get that
[__] out of the
chain d t
me
binging Eugene got that
tambourine how the [__] do I get there
how the [__] how the
[__] was there a note
here oh there we got this okay okay come
on yeah oh I see that'll do that'll
do check the ball game
mmm I don't
who all right no more boats I get H boss
time damn sexy son of a
[__] uh let me throw uh this at him
okay so
wonder whether you [__]
Seattle is he throwing stuff at
me surprise
[__] Jesus oh God
sizzles all right all
right oh [__]
we got both of them that' be
good uh let me just let me just let it
bro oh that's not
good throw it why does it not give me
the
option there we
go whoops [__]
up
whoa excuse me big
chungus got you [__]
nice sorry about that
bro so sorry about that
okay back to that damn Ferris
wheel after I play Patriot and wings my
favorite
game
see I don't need Eugene to shoot a bunch
of
blanks I got this the game
easy lowkey want to turn him into a
drink I feel like a fizzy drink with his
flavor would be really [__]
tasty new G fuel flavor question
mark that could be
cool num
n
what do we got
here you definitely improved thanks guys
thanks my gamer roots coming
back some vintage toys here could
probably go for a lot
oh yeah we should get some
thans now we're full health
sweet can we go back to the boat now I
want to get in the
boat okay cool we're on this side of the
dude this is a cool [__] place I
would love to visit this in does this
exist in
Seattle
I need
tape oh sweet oh
sweet the hell did this used to
be what the
[__] in uh Tokyo
in oh [__] what is it called The Island
area of
Tokyo they have a vintage uh arcade
place with super old arcade machines
it's so
[Music]
fun garbage island I don't know what
it's called I keep
forgetting this this Land Cafe bro take
me back man let's play DotA
man DOTA one not Dota
2 laser tag
yeah I should do that in UK
sometime I know this one in Brighton but
it feels so trashy now I don't know why
we did a paintball on my stag
party I had an amazing stack party I
don't know if I ever talked about it
Joel roomy organized the whole thing he
did such a good job I had such a that
was such a memorable day but I said I
wanted to shoot guns he's like what do
you want to
do I want to [__] shoot guns it's my
snag
party so he legit looked into uh
flying to like Eastern European
countries where you're allowed to shoot
guns I'm like [__] I mean [__] uh
shotguns or anything would have been
fine I know you can shoot those in
Bri so we ended up playing uh paintball
instead and I don't think anyone enjoyed
the
paintball cuz it [__]
hurts it was so fun like it was a fun
memory but everyone was just like [__]
this let's move on to the next
activity all right [__] do I was I
supposed to go upstairs sorry I got
distracted by all
story I didn't get shot that much I was
supposed to be the Target because it's
my S party right
so uh [__] how do I go up again it was
over here
right and I'm such a
[__] Jack got completely
[__] one of my Swedish friends who
were there Aus he's kind of a Loose
Cannon and at the very end it was
supposed to be freefor all in paintball
so such a [__] mad line uh no one
really wanted to do the free-for-all
like we were okay just playing teams and
by the rules but free-for all basically
me you can shoot whatever the [__] you
want so everyone just ran to the safe
zone right away there was two safe zones
one on each side it was so funny Finding
Me Jack and Joel I think it was in the
safe zone or was
it and we both basically just laughed
and we were like okay so if there's ever
War we know who's going to be the the
ones who run CU we just [__] bailed
but then my SW friend aus was coming
towards the safe safe
spot [__] the game is so loud I don't
know if you can hear me uh so I was like
Aus don't shoot us we're in the safe
spot you were not allowed to shoot in
the safe spot what the [__] does Aus do
I knew he was crazy I knew he was going
to do something cuz I hid in the safe
spot Jack and uh whoever else was in
there I don't remember didn't so he
shoots inside the same spot Jack starts
bleeding from the shots it's [__]
crazy
crazy it's kind of awkward I can tell he
got pissed but he was cool with it
anyway I'd be [__] pissed like [__]
this guy it's funny as hell
[Music]
though I really ow Joe big time for
organizing that day we did a ton of cool
stuff it was fully
packed holy [__] these are not safe
Waters Ellie what are you
[Music]
doing no not
now this is not
starting called
[Music]
it that would be a nice time for another
flashback but that rest in peace boat
you served this
well [__] it I can make
it is she going to have to Dish some of
the weapon this feels like the part of
the game where you lose all the stuff
you built up
is it better to swim under the water if
it's really
wavy does that work in real
life I guess
so let's do this
yeah you think there's something in
here I look I become everything I
hate looting
everything is there something here can I
crawl
in why would there be ammo here it makes
no sense I don't even know why I'm
looking why would there be ammo
scattered in a game shop yeah you're
right all
right oh oh oh
he who's ready the [__] Abby
up I don't know I
am I'm looking for the cross spot I'm
sure it's here
somewhere okay Abby where are
you we're getting close to Abby now
a
snail hya a whale a crab dude Mr
Crab and Last of Us 10 out of 10 game I
changed my
mind become a member guys thanks for
becoming a member on the live stream uh
you become whatever these are called in
English legit appreciate all the
members except the ones that get their
dick shoed up [__]
you that sounded like transphobia that's
not what I just meant oh no oh
no yeah maybe the cutting off dick joke
isn't a good
idea it's cutting have peee it all right
I just say peee instead that makes it
more
clear start sweating no don't cancel
please I didn't mean
[Music]
it uh so anyway sag party yeah we also
went in a Jacuzzi like one of those boat
jaudes a Jacuzzi that is a
boat that was
epic all right we're in the
aquarium a it's kind of sad to think all
the animals died
here during the
apocalypse maybe they just let them
loose should I have explored more in
there poor jellyfish they just went
bye-by you
know AB at
tomor oh she'll pay for this
[Music]
[__] now I lost where I
were where I was there it
is damn that's a lot of
plank bing bang bing bang bong bing bang
Bing
okay I guess I can make another one yes
no I already have one confused noises oh
it's tape that I
wanted I'm just making this for the sake
of it I don't need it but we got a
bottle
here I guess the stunned ones are for
people that want to play the game
without killing
people we should use them on the dogs
but then again I feel bad even stunning
them what is all this stuff
it's an aquarium Ellie what do you what
do you mean This Is How They Run the
[__]
e
ew oh that's so
disgusting we need to cancel the
water I'm sick of
it
why you zoom it look it didn't look as
bad zoomed
actually Trypophobia
gang I got a pee but I feel like I can
hold it it's one of those that's kind of
smoothed out kind of P if you just sit
really
still they should be fine
so as long as there's no jump scares I I
think we're
good there's a hook thing here I feel
like that should be used so I need to go
over there but I can climb across
anything except
those maybe I need to go down here
somewhere oh yeah
definitely ankle broken
gang everyone keeps like uh thinking I
hate playing the game I look dead inside
and I think in the beginning I was but
it's kind of using up on me a
bit I just in general I feel really
happy that I'm able to stream I'm so
glad I decided to stream this game cuz
it's much more fun with people here I
think if I was alone I probably would
have hated
it where the [__] is this
bit
where the [__] are you yeah right Ellie
is everything reload
nope oh because I don't have enough ammo
that's there's definitely No Loot here
so I don't even know why I'm keep
looking keep looking yes I speak
English always wear your lab cods and
safety goggles come on Ellie are you
crazy it's always like if you're stuck
just look up in this game and you'll
find the
way go pee so I can pee all right if you
someone have to pee save it up all right
and we'll all go and pee on the same
time we'll have a synchronized pee it'
be like the most bonding moment we'll
ever
have okay so don't pee yet if you have
to just hold it oh
God
Jesus no not the dog
no go away
shush no
no
stop
[__] I hate this game stupid dog sh
there was not a stupid dog that was BJ
I'll sing a song in your
honor
ban
beon
Bean he was like father to
me that was Abby's dog she's got to be
in
here I think we're maxed out
dude do I have tape now I do have tape
now
sweet what about
pills
not worth
it yo
God [__] happened
here this is
spoopy H
am I maxed out
nope no jump scares please yeah hold
hold your pee a little longer not too
long though if you really got to go you
got to go I respect it
but we'll have a synchronized Peak
together it'll be epic
just like five more minutes you can do
it people don't come back from that
Island how many times is Abby risk her
life for you yeah shoot them both I'm
not [__] going there then
don't go
back he looks so
silly [__]
you hands up so does
she
where's
Abby you're that girl from Jackson tell
me where she
went how do we know you won't kill us
give her what she wants and we're dead
you guys can survive this I just need
her
[__] yeah she's
right the girl on the right reminds me
of someone and I can't put my finger on
it come here is she going to do the
interrogation thing that [__] get
over here
point to where she is on this
map and then
you it better [__] match
up she did it that's cool okay what are
you doing she's probably dead anyway it
is not worth it stop we can talk about
shut the [__]
up point to where she she
is [__]
[Music]
Bo is this the part where I click the
button really
fast shouldn't have pull the knife on
me help me
Point tell me where Abby
is [__] is she damn Ellie [__]
hell thank you Grand broker appreciate
you Minecraft will be back I got
you all right after this cut scene ready
to run to the
toilet
even if you're watching offline let's go
ahead
it you ready oh oh it's Tommy whoa whoa
hey
hey [__] now I actually really have to
pee God damn it it's all right hey come
on let's go let's
go it's all
right damn it come on just
end
endure go go go go go go go
[Music]
go
h
[Music]
for
by
I'm just getting some
water
do we feel the same sense of
relief do we both feel that ah
sensation I missed the part oh
no [__] what happened give me a quick
run
now oh my God what the [__] did I miss
Tommy
die
what the
[__] Joel is
alive what did I
miss what did I miss seriously stop
trolling
me what did I miss just tell
me [__] a crossbow
no you're trolling me nothing happened
you [__]
trolls guess we're back here
huh what the [__] there
much
what the
[__] all this is like this Hub area
isn't
it get there this
whole Tommy died huh Tommy died huh some
[__]
you what do you guys doing up couldn't
sleep come take a look at this thought
is to head home via
Ellensburg we're in Fall cityor we're
doing
good
hey they got what they deserved for
sure no she gets to
live no
regrets no regrets
yeah is that
okay
uh no it has to
be do you remember hitting that girl
with a pipe five times Ellie do you do
you forget about that what you should be
worried about is what Maria is going to
do to you when we get home we bent their
worse
however I was passing through some ritzy
section of town I come across this
necklace sparkles a lot I think it's
real gold you think it's real gold it's
real gold let's see
it I know what gold looks
like if it's legit can we say it's from
all I'm going to watch through what I
missed later you find your own damn BR
luckily I am
recording has she told you she's
pregnant
yet how you doing
fine Ellie
fine Ellie's really good at talking
about her emotions I got to
say thanks for coming back for
me my friend's problems are my
problems you're such a
sap all right how about get it sap
sapling plant monster my friends can't
get out their own damn
way it's
better
[__] what Jessie stand up you're J get
that oh you're so dead you're so dead
get out of here stand up you're done Mo
your [__] dare shut the [__] up
that's the time to pull out a gun and
shoot it in the face all right stop
stop oh my God she has a gun and she
didn't shoot what the [__] is wrong with
you toss your weapon no El Diablo no no
El
Diablo you better not kill [__] Tommy
killed
Joel he did what he did to save me there
is no cure because of me I am the one
that you
want just let him go the
[__] you killed my friends no I didn't
they uh slipped into the shower you both
live and you wasted it tomm me do
something chew on an
ankle F in the chat for Eugene I was
like oh he's being really sweet this is
a wholesome moment that means he's going
to die but it would happen very quick in
this
game dad oh no [__] this [__] this I
don't don't give a [__] come on no no
you do not no
no well maybe now we get to find out how
she got so [__] strong
dad all right can I pick up the gun and
shoot myself how do I do that end this
now I can change
this how do I do I just pick up the gun
[__] all right let's find a cliff I can
jump off up okay let's try this see if I
can jump up here this might be high
enough I didn't die okay um
H maybe climb a
tree maybe if I hit my head in
this look she can't even crawl
under
dad come
on you can't keep doing
this Joel killed aby's Dad okay cool I
don't
care don't care gang
dad squirrel
gang where are
you [__] this I don't want to play as
her
what the
hell ain't
happening no you don't get to do
that whoa
jeez all right maybe I can hit myself in
the how do I do that how do I hit myself
in the
head I got to say I heard that people
were really mean or toxic to the voice
actress of this game just cuz I hate the
character does not mean I have any
resentment so please don't be just don't
be that person it's so annoying when
people take it too far so what if you
don't like the
game I hate that
is he in the
Stalls Eugene went
bye-bye what the [__] am I doing in
here there we go not
worked can't get through here maybe I
can get onto the roof maybe I can drink
this
bleach try
that I got to move these I
don't I don't want
[Music]
to look at that
1978 people did the same with the actors
of act during Game of Thrones like they
young king he quit acting cuz people
were just so toxic it's [__] up cuz
people didn't like his character it's
like what the [__] is wrong with people
can you not draw a
distinction smooth
heavy am I crazy to think okay crazy
thought I haven't processed it yet so it
might sound outlandish
let me think about
it
ABS shoot me shoot me you uh shoot me
please you got a little mud on you there
sweetheart so do you where right
there you know every time you run off
like this they give me [__] about it
come on believe it or not they actually
care about your safety these Woods are
safe dad ABS she's been hanging out
right on the other side of those trees
and she's due any day now we'll just
check on her and then then we'll head
back I
promise her name is ABS let's just make
it
quick see I've got my little girl to
keep me
safe
how' you know I was here Owen ratted
didn't he people kept saying Abby is
friends but with this flashback it
doesn't seem like she is I could be
wrong um uh I
asked can someone tell me so I don't say
anything stupid about it feel free to
spoil
she probably cut through the playground
come
on hey look what I
found oh she is trans no she
1978 don't have that one in my
collection I don't think she is you can
keep it if you promise not to pull
anything like this
again you got yourself a deal why don't
I believe believe you no reason I could
think
of well someone mentioned that uh like
it could have been insensitive of me
when I said pointed out that she's so
buff and that it was like she used to be
a man and then that transs to a
girl I don't see a problem pointing out
that someone's really [__] buff more
so than usual oh God it's impressive
regardless how long have you
known I'm your dad I see things like the
way you both try really really each
other when you're around you get all
serious it's very cute I can't do this
and he makes you laugh that's let's find
some steroids and overdose let's get a
game it's like how he's extra nice to me
now he gets all nervous when he hey crab
made a reappearance sweet so you're
taking advantage of him me
never sorry I realized I talked over in
this entire thing I it's just I don't
know
ABS Fresh
Tracks I prefer the Joel and Ellie find
nice wholesome wait this is just your
sneaky way of giving me a tracking
lesson isn't it I would never damn
that's hot is it working snail made it
back well I mean I found you yeah but
you cheated you do what you need to do
to get it
done e that's a lung uh dad I found
something oh my God she already gave
birth oh that's not a lung two sets of
tracks that's a dad it's her let's go
that doesn't sound good no all right now
I can shoot him and maybe he shoots me
does that make
sense oh you can't do it damn it
um um did I do something wrong come
on that wait what if they were infected
she's so buff dad calls her ABS you know
they roll you brought your G right of
course then I'm not
worried I say what I say in the
beginning that's got to be a reason they
made her so [__] strong oh [__] abs
what God a see bre we got to cut her
loose it's okay con don't worry there's
no reason I'm not going to hurt
you it's okay damn it it's really in
there uh ABS come here here
I'm going to hold her okay [__]
had pliers and calm down calm down calm
down stop are you around here over here
Owen
what hey get over here and help me hold
what a face we need you back up just
help
him Jesus [__]
Christ ABS do you want to be any more
useless right you got her tight uh
yeah all right get in there
ABS
steady okay
done holy [__] Run's on a land mine
everybody's looking for you we got to
hey wait
Dad what's going
on come
on
oh
cool we did good back there Snipes them
doc that girl showed up what girl the
one Marlene keeps talking about they
found her in the tunnels she has an old
bite mark on her arm no signs of
infection that can't be they're already
running tests on her but you got to get
down
there
dad come
[Music]
on so is that the dock from the
beginning that Joel shoots that we saw
in the beginning of the game is Abby's
Dad could that be it intertwin with the
brain there's no other option there has
to be some other way there's no way to
remove the specimen without we need them
to like Abby somehow let's make them
save a zebra that'll make them change
their mind P dish you think I
don't I'm aware of the situation it's
definitely him no I'm okay with
developing a vaccine that will help save
millions of lives how many fireflies
have died for Less that was their
choice are you asking me are you telling
me this is how it's going to be I I'm
begging you to buy in and what if this
was
happy yeah what do you do then look
everything that we've been fighting for
all the sacrifices all the
horrific all of that is Justified with
this one
act if this was your
daughter what would you
do Abby I got some chicken and beans
from the zebra what the [__] is wrong
with you Abby Jesus Christ can she get
any
worse look
marene do
it thank
you I'm going to go tell Joel
why he traveled across the country with
her he has a right to know not to be old
vegan schmeer but they save the zebra
and brings out a [__]
steak doesn't really
feel that
right why is that funny
thing
[Music]
yeah she needs the games
bro she's Natty don't worry just ate a
lot of
zebras so that's how she got all musly
of
course dude the amount of protein in
zebras I've read about it
online they packing so much [__]
protein one bite 20% muscle
increase
that's not vegan uh Emoji never been so
appropriate all right
so yeah this is the hospitals from the
beginning that's
cool I think it's an interesting uh
contrast to follow the fireflies
perspective a little
bit AB be how can go [__]
building oh yeah he was the do three
shot holy [__] I was
right I mean it wasn't that surprising
but
[Music]
still you know in the beginning when
when they were talking about as someone
else being pregnant with
get up Joel [__] get up I don't want
to see this again please
stop please don't
Jesus Joel please get
up I still feel
nothing for that
[Laughter]
[__] oh what the [__] dude [__] kill
what's wrong with you man cleaning up no
no no we're here for you how much worse
can they make it Jesus Christ [__]
bad he's right we can't have
lense we killed them we're no better
than he was no don't shoot them they
didn't do Abby that Spar them huh look
at my face [__] your face you should
been guarding the upstairs like I told
you to move back up calm down or what
back the [__] up calm
down you shoot me stop
we're
done interesting what was I saying
before
[Music]
[__] Abby oh right the
baby
you okay ABS yeah
just what's up been searching everywhere
for
you we've been called up Isaac wants us
at the front what are you serious I'm
afraid
so we should
hustle we're leaving
now yes I'm us okay so what I was saying
stop talking so I can talk this is my
time to shine excuse me Last of
Us [__] hell she's so buff [__] I got
to get me some zebra man does anyone
know a zebra guy thanks for giving me
their room last night yeah who was it
this time that cook chick nah the
weather chick she's down from the
mountain oh the scientist nice H she's a
little too excited about her job talk
much okay I just want to tell my
hypothesis
so in the beginning she said something
his uh the other guy with the hair and
said something about a baby and she
seemed really jealous so I thought or
like hurtful so I thought Joel killed
her kid or something like that and
that's why she was so vengeful but
you're about I yeah sucks to get your
dad killed though oh absolutely I can
die happy now I guess for us to
sympathize I I expected a bit more
better than
her I keep thinking the same thing and
yet cuz I really don't sympathize with
ABY mainly
cuz
uh Joel saved their life more than once
and she didn't even hesitate to [__]
shoot him and torture
him especially the torture bit I guess
that's the weird part as
well a the young l
hello
hello Skywalk gentleman never tells
Master Abby
wow do we not have any mods in the chat
anymore what's going
on
all
right what do you want from
me super star of the month way to go
Luca I got to talk to my dad for a
second grab us some food yeah on it get
me something compant you get what you
get
y don't want to play as Abby but this is
the game for some
reason nice to see you too Abby hey we
got some zebra
tonights excuse me who the [__]
talking oh [__] Jordan I didn't see you
there you coming with us to the cavina
Manny and I just got called up to the
fob what are you doing at the Cen hotel
and the school are getting evacuated
we're grabbing supplies and bringing
everyone back to the base
seriously man can you [__] believe
after everything we're falling back you
don't know that's what it is at least
station sooner well there's that
yeah I should run may your survival be
long and may your death be Swift oh I'll
make sure it ain't I'll make sure it
[__]
ain't all right let's get some zebra got
to get those gains
bro what's on the menu boys you have to
your
KN that's the zebra right there you know
it [__] Abby brought it in I know it
it's a four-year-old zebra that's how
long you have to wait burritos again
okay dude I can have burritos every
[__] day what's the
problem hey man there's a line Kenny
what the [__] kiss me wait your turn
like the rest oh now she's gone too far
so embarrassing oh my God why do you
have three go on
back now don't freak out M's coming with
us Manny Abby cut in ly where's your
pack who the [__] do you think you are
Abby why are you doing this to me
because I care about both of you and I'm
tired of I'm going here does she know
I'm on this drive she does all right so
now we just stop playing and then
everything will be fine right she sat in
there with her burrito sound like a
no it's my accent come on stop being
paranoid okay you kill Joel maybe I'm
willing to forgive but you cut in line
for a
burrito the [__] wrong with you
Abby
I make me uncomfortable no it's an
opportunity for you two to finally move
forward we barely said a word to each
other since Jackson I'm just supposed to
pretend that didn't happen of course not
you guys need to talk about it she want
to draw dirad as much as the rest of us
but she's not like I want to see how she
looks like when she eats she hasn't hurt
people like that
before she she kills scars all the time
not the way we kill Joe don't forget we
are grunts she's a medic come on Abby
she's family do it for me dude she eats
the paper [__] psycho that's all I'm
asking for you didn't even finish it all
right how do you get how did she get the
gains she doesn't even [__] finish a
burrito how' she get those
gains
the [__] did she just litter as
well what are they
doing get your things ready I'm going to
grab now yeah be nice bite
[Music]
me
I'll do it later of course of
course kago Katana
epic shadow of the
sword I know nongo it's whatever I
didn't read it underneath
whoa
what that is cool if only Abby wasn't so
big I could actually see
it thanks
Abby wait scientist huh oh thank
God what am I doing in
here PR for the week I'd be strong ready
to whoa yeah just about
oh she was a
[Music]
mother
hi hey actually cleared you for active
duty
barely you could probably get a stay if
you ask I'd rather not sit around if I
don't have to no one's okay with this
why would it be up to
Owen we need to grab Alice on our
way
hey do
better
at least she's a unique
character I don't think there's anyone
like Abby in the
world what are you getting called up for
it's just a usual rotation don't worry
hey uh when you get back will you check
on my dad oh my God it seems I don't
know worse worse how well he's
complaining about a sharpening his wrist
that is not enough area to sustain May
okay they got down here what's up
hey heard they moved you and ow into
seor
96 yeah it's it's nice it's lot of young
families getting you guys excited about
the baby seeing all the kids running
around uh yeah I'm I'm getting ready
where the zebra at where the where the
zebra at I want the Zebra meat we
cooking Z de tonight
boys all those crying babies those drive
all with Grace ew melon and Abby my two
least favorite things Danny yikes sucks
for him
yeah
everything is being prepared for Abby
Abby need them
games how do I not like watermelon well
take a guess signing out Alice she's
plain inside I'm not mentioning the name
of the devil want to grab her
hey
girl you crazy dog there's my favorite
girl the only one that'll put up with
your [__] don't be
jealous is that the one we killed before
you want to go to the trucks let's go to
the trucks I think it is isn't
he hey there
Bear yeah okay since it's bear
bear is back oh now we're going to feel
bad can you believe you killed bear
Felix I had no choice you left me no
choice but to kill this [__]
dog get the
ball wow good job bear you did
it Drop
It Go Get It Go Get It get
it sorry buddy my
bad muscle too strong sorry couldn't
control
myself did I see last night yes you did
you dirty dog I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so
sorry something
for it's got to be a long job she really
likes it ask her about the kum's clout
rest in peace ball well I guess you get
to stay away from the combat yeah that's
what you're Abby did it not me i' be
happy staying put just treating families
good means [__] out scars I don't
think so i' go
crazy hey Pat
hey hey Pat can I have my usual you got
it
gracias which trucks are in this is very
dragged out take
s24 I'm
driving sign us
out when did she die I don't get it may
your survival be long may your death be
swift W not combat as abuse warm
up what gun is this assault rifle what
kind
of yeah yeah a
good I missed
you 10 hours of Abby
10's wait
what is that
real no joke 10 hours with this
character
yes it's real yes you're going to play
the next 10
hour [__] sake what a joke oh no no no
no for the love of God no I don't know
anymore you could use a
sh give you two a chance to talk do it
real
s why is a pregnant lady going out in
combat she doesn't
see you what the
hell have you been sleeping these
days not
great do you want me to get you
something from the
pharmacy no I'm I'm good wow Abby's a
real smooth talker it's fine I'm just
going to wear myself out I've been
picking up a few extra
assignments you
and what do you
mean
nothing hey Manny where are you headed
two truck s24 headed to two May survival
be long and your dead be
swift we lost a hatchery
yeah need plan on getting it
back n Isaac says it's low priority
we're fishing enough wild salmon right
now does anything happen ow
um I haven't seen him in like 2
weeks he keeps picking up open
assignments has he talked to you did did
he say anything or no we're still not I
mean I I seen him in the mall but we
walk around each
other all right back to tap P you know I
wouldn't read too much into
it a [__] hey Ambush hang
on Mel stay low kill
the they were waiting for
us take them out the [__] you think
we're
doing get closer is she wearing the baby
as armor like why is she out in combat
break get us out of this
I'm get keep coming
it's kind of awkward to shoot am I not
supposed to aim at
them
oh oh no AB is dying this is so say no I
shot the horse [__]
[__] I keep
missing I never felt less incentivized
to
shoot why is she you okay why
yeah [__] scars how far away from the
fob it's a hike Abby shot the horse
[__] insane person let's get
inside oh perfectly reloaded with the
same amount I ammo
epic slight happy noise the more damage
happy
takes happiness
increase
I don't want
these hey
ABS there's enough stuff here to make a
buy
bomb copy
that cool now we can blow oursel
up all right finally all right let's do
it boys so long let's take him with us
hold up stay still stand still let's
make sure Dogg is okay and baby all
right boys lot of places to hide in here
it's been
real no game over we did it skip the 12
hours no I have to play
it damn
it all right it was worth a shot at
least let's
go oh
man are those
zombies
can we sneak up on
her door
gang
[Music]
yeah Jesus we just choked them oh my
god
um why are we doing this now like I know
how to kill
zombies speedrun please
okay just don't want the dog to die you
know
okay that's
quicker all right let's try and get
through this we
clear speedrun anyone got a
timer
what one hit
KO
where am I
going here there's a
hold guys look up there see the light
coming through could be a way
up sorry I forgot I'm supposed to Speed
Run dude this is so weird
here we
go I missed something
there why have an axe when you can one
punch
then oh that was
badly oh no I get
no
no what were they
thinking
no
what no I don't want to spec
out oh oh I died
good got God dang
it stop crouching
Abby hold up so where do I go then
oh no oh [__]
oh hang on jump on
it oh
no oh this
sucks good
doggy here they come come
on
what I should
have I could have grabbed him
whoa last clutch
bro oh they got a
boom hell yeah look at
this no don't get me
please
got him should I use the pipe
pump oh come
on well now he's Double
Dead forgot I had this
rifle
[__] that it yeah can we say [__] this
place yes [__] this place
don't [__] swear
Abby was that a
boss
guys I'm going to play a couple more
minutes and then I'm going to end this
one been live for a while
and Abby could have opened that on her
own
ladies
first notice how Abby doesn't go I'm
just kidding that's a bad he said ladies
first yeah got
him you can be musly as hell and and be
lady green shouldn't I respect the games
I respect the zra eating good point you
know what this is good two needed a b
shut up man working
already
oh why does this feel
like they shouldn't have done this I
don't this part sucks I don't want to
play I don't I don't want it I don't
want it I already lacked so much
connection with the other characters I
don't need to reset the whole game and
rebuild whatever the [__] they
was you know what I
mean I definitely don't give a [__]
about
these
no all right whenever you're stuck it's
always look up that's the rule of this
game
here we
go I can't go up
there why
not all right then [__] help me
God
okay
Bob's Dead Ahead no scars
inside well they're out there is there a
golf side quest let's keep
moving God remember when we could pass
through this area without getting jumped
by
scars don't
care the game is trying to make me stop
I can't stop oh loot I can't
stop no more
loot I'm
done oh God it physically hurts I can't
help it I'm sorry guys I'm weak I'm weak
I can't help
it not to against us but it is very
quiet out of here keep checking those
sight
lines
[__] something's blocking the door maybe
there's another way
in all right speedrun up here [__] all
right
speedrun Manny see what's up there on
it what the [__] I'm playing as no I
thought they switched
character who's a good boy we need to be
on the other side cut through one of the
buildings cuz that worked out so well
last time do you have another idea Manny
Noe just
venting there you go come on up Mel stay
with Alice I'll try to get that door
open find you two another way in cool be
careful
Abby is as useless as a jump button in
this
game forgot there was
one do Abby off
stream yeah I'm bored I'm just bored I
don't want to tell you I'm stopping
here all right guys thank you for
joining the stream I still had fun this
is a bit of a something we're going to
have to get
through God I hope you're trolling me I
don't know who to trust
anymore we've been streaming for a long
time but thanks for everyone for joining
it a good
time always fun hanging out with you
guys except when you troll me but that's
it uh bye ABS
bye all right see you guys next time
take care